as coronavirus cases are spiking across
the country middlemen are driving up the
price of those highly coveted n95 masks
those masks are needed for frontline
workers a CBS News investigation found a
top supporter of the president is trying
to cash in on that market and Jim
Axelrod explains they are the gold
standard of masks giving healthcare
workers maximum protection against the
coronavirus n95 mask so in early April
with us supplies of n95 dwindling it
can't be that we can't make these and
doctors and nurses sounding the alarm
the president took aim at 3m America's
biggest mask maker mr. Trump tweeted the
company will have a big price to pay for
exporting n95 to Canada and Latin
America the tweet set off four days of
negotiations until 3m and the White
House struck a deal so we're getting one
hundred and sixty six point five million
masks which is where this man comes in
finally we have a president guy you know
promises and delivers Eric beech is a
big-time fund raiser for the president
the Great America PAC which he
co-founded has raised more than forty
million dollars to support mr. Trump
since 2016
he creates policies that allow all
Americans to flourished not just a
certain segment of Americans and beech
did not let an opportunity to try to
make some money go to waste four days
after the president struck a deal with
3m beech who has no experience in
medical supplies formed Colt
international incorporated touting his
connections with the manufacturing giant
CBS News obtained this document sent to
prospective clients by one of Colts
quote preferred partners a letter
apparently signed by beech assures
buyers colt would work directly with the
3m corporation and its distributors and
provides his direct contact information
another document from Beach's partner
boasts the Colts relationship with 3m
would provide local governments
hospitals and first responders access to
a current inventory of several billion
units of the urgently needed n95 masks I
don't know how somebody can have that
many masks shashank Amalapuram runs a
medical equipment company supplying
hospitals and nursing homes with
protective equipment
he told us n95 s are still backordered
up to three months I want to talk to you
about Colt international this is
directly from the document direct
pricing and low minimum order quantities
of n95 masks through 3m hundreds of
emails from people who claim to have
millions of masks with them I have
stayed away from it because it's too
dubious Beach told CBS News his new
business was quote connecting friends
and colleagues he subleased office space
at this political lobbying firm in Reno
Nevada according to a document from
Colts partners they were offering masks
for up to two dollars and 20 cents each
a markup of 93 cents above three M's
list price and that's before a 10%
commission on the final sale you can do
the math you know it's huge 3m said it
had seen a surge of middlemen trying to
cash in on the pandemic by falsely
claiming affiliation with the company to
drum up business the manufacturer told
CBS News it had no relationship with
Beach's company Colt international but
you could easily get the impression but
wait a minute he's connected with 3m
that is true for anybody who is not in
the business any Hospital it sounds that
way you know this is coming directly
from 3m that gives a lot of you know
legitimacy when you're making a sale in
a statement to CBS News Beach said he
only worked to connect medical buyers
through various contacts and admitted he
had no professional relationship with 3m
Tony well that's the big question here
Jim so from your reporting what would
this political operative this fundraiser
Eric Beach stand to gain by creating the
impression that he was connected in some
way with 3m
well our reporting suggests of course
that it is designed to give the
impression look we're the real deal we
can supply all the masks that you need
the only problem is States and hospitals
and other people who desperately need
n95 masks there's no evidence that they
can deliver so those entities could have
their money tied up with beach that
could go instead towards actual n95
masks Wow all right Jim Axelrod
reporting for us Jim thank you very much